what can we learn from the last two
years living in a global pandemic
michael lewis is a best-selling author
of the fifth risk the big short and
money ball his latest book the
premonition looks at the official
response to the covert outbreak by the
u.s administration i spoke to him
earlier
michael thanks so much uh for coming on
the show um i've read lots of your books
and it's really really great to meet you
totally
so thanks for coming on and
i want to start with um
the fifth risk which is a political
journalist i have to say i found
absolutely fascinating it's this story
of the transition from obama to trump
and basically what a mess it was um
trump resistance to even having a
transition
team hundreds of posts uh left empty but
before we get into the book and what
it's about and also been making into a
tv series can you explain to the viewers
what does the fifth uh what does the
fifth risk actually mean
well the title comes from a conversation
i had with someone who was managing
existential risks in part of the u.s
government and i was just asking him
like what are the top five risks that
you worry about in your little
department the department of energy so
i'm worried about nuclear weapons going
off when they shouldn't go off and we
spend a lot of time thinking about that
or not going off if we need them to go
off uh you know i'm worried about the
reign the the iran nuclear deal because
we're in the middle of that so he's
listing then he gets to five
and when he gets to the fifth one
it's such a boris boring sounding one
but it ended up being right at the
center of the story i was telling it and
he said it's he says the fifth risk i'm
going to call it program management and
with it what i mean by that is there are
these risks that the united states
government are managing that are inter
they go through for generations they're
long-term risks
and that if we take our eye off the ball
catastrophic things can happen and there
are these things throughout the federal
government so when i thought called the
fifth i was thinking like
these are the risks you as a citizen are
oblivious to you're just taking it for
granted that your government is handling
it in some way more or less competently
at the same time you yourself probably
think very little of your government
because you're an american and americans
have been trained to hate their
government what happens if this goes
wrong uh and the so the book that was
that was kind of a starting point there
is the fifth risk there are all these uh
risks within government and then
president trump is elected
it tells you a lot about the state of
our society right that and
what so by law
the outgoing administration in that case
the obama administration is required to
prepare briefings for the income
administration because our government
unlike yours is is managed by
presidential appointees not career civil
servants so
4 000 plus people are going to roll in
with a new president and they're going
to have to be you know appointed by him
and confirmed by the senate to run all
these different agencies okay let me ask
you another question because viewers
here might think in the uk might think
trump's it's done it's over there's a
biden it's a new era but how worried are
you about trump coming back and becoming
the president again in 2024
are you worried about do you think it's
a possibility of course it's a
possibility and of course it's
unpredictable if you ask me to put um
odds on it i'd say five to one against i
don't think it's the likely outcome why
because you think the republicans will
rely on different candidates yes i do
and i think um
he's not good at being president
i mean he didn't there
if he had been run you know like a half
decent pandemic response he'd still be
president that his incompetence ends up
being a big issue and we're going to
come onto the phone but before i do just
quickly because the thing also about the
fifth i mean everyone should read it i
actually listen to it on a pod i listen
to the audio book um but also it's been
made into a um netflix drama right just
came out yeah i said
by the bar the obama production company
yes so how did that come about had they
got why did the obamas want to televise
a um
a book about
that's so critical of trump who's their
own gender there no i tell you what's
funny about it
you would think it sounds the way you
just put that
obama saw an anti-trump thing yeah and
thought i will put that on top that is
what i thought it's the the opposite
that they've been bending over backwards
the obamas to avoid engaging in the in
any kind of political overt political
kind of messaging activity
what attracted obama you know so it
counted against the book
that it had this kind of
anti-trump
undertone
would appeal to him about it
was it was the first
attempt to really describe what the hell
the government did you know like this
this these exist this management of
existential risks that nobody knew about
he really liked the idea of basically
delivering an entertaining civics lesson
i thought maybe part of the obama's
motivation uh for televising this was to
actually kind of send a warning to
america as they saw it of don't make the
same mistake twice guys if this man runs
in 2024 but that wasn't it was a
different warning it was the delivery it
was the warning was you neglect this
government that you have
at your peril what's he like what's it
like doing a project with him
well i i met him because i wrote about
him i wrote a big piece for vanity fair
years ago and i kind of moved into his
life in the white house when he was
president and got to know him a bit then
in some ways a very unlikely politician
in that
he's you don't feel like you're with a
politician you feel like you know what
he's he's got the he's got the
temperament the personality of a writer
fun to be with i was very fond of him i
mean interesting guy
i i
i think i told him once it may have
offended him that
um
if he was not black i don't think he'd
have been president because the fact
that he was black disguised people
disguised just how
unpolitical he was unlike a politician
he was
um
that how
how
peculiar he was
and the truth is that this man would
never have been a politician if he had a
successful literary career he started
out wanting to write short stories and
they didn't get accepted and i think i
so i think he's like a writer who
stumbled into politics and found found a
calling
um
but you mis you do mistake him if you
think like the reason he grabbed my book
was it was a way to needle donald trump
it was the opposite he told the
producers that leave trump to one side
this isn't about trump they didn't
listen to him completely of course but
how could you one thing that really
astonished me in the book is the moment
where you say
trump finds out he's won pennsylvania's
called and then karen pence goes to hug
mike pence the vice president or so mike
goes to hug karen yeah and and sort of
for congratulations she kind of pushes
him away so it's not like you got what
what she you got what you want she was
offended by him offended by who mike
pence or donald trump or both of them
donald trump and mike pence's pence's
allegiance to him at that moment you got
what you wanted mike leave me alone i
mean you got to remember this is uh
these are
these are
she's a good christian lady from middle
america and donald trump is violating
everything she believes in left and
right and uh i think she was offended by
him i've never heard her say that but
that was i i interviewed people who
watched that encounter
and so who knows exactly what was going
on in her head let's go on to um
about the pandemic the pandemic book the
premonition
um
you talk about that um about the what
happened in the u.s it was a uk for us
it was a traumatic experience to 180 000
deaths here in the u.s with a much
bigger population of course a million
deaths in your book you say america the
west developed the tools to defeat to
pandemic but america didn't implement
those tools
what do you mean by that was that a
trump problem
or a us government problem it's the most
remarkable story we both share and we
kind of both share the story
there was a study in 2019 done at great
expense millions of dollars hundreds of
experts to determine this before the
pandemic which countries on the planet
were best equipped to deal with a
pandemic like who had the resources who
were who was who was going to respond
best
the united states came out number one in
the uk came out number two
so we in theory are best prepared for
this in practice our death rates were
off the charts i mean we're kind of like
i don't know where the u.s is now but we
were 120th somewhere down there you know
yemen out performs this kind of thing
and so that was what the beginning what
interested me is like what happened have
you come up with the conclusion that we
would be better or worse equipped to
cope with a
another pandemic as the result of the
covet experience
we as a world or we as a united states
well let's do both so we as the united
states are clearly worse off
why um because
there's not only no agreement
on what we did right and what we did
wrong
this active disagreement and 40 of the
country won't get vaccinated forty
percent of the country thinks that the
social interventions were
pointless but but certainly it would be
hard it would be harder to lead the
country but michael is that not just
partly also not about the sort of
about the who was in power i mean you
know some of the disinformation i
remember watching that press conference
agog as donald trump said you know what
we could do i remember you know we could
um inject disinfectant as a corona for
coronado i remember i was watching and
then dr bridge this sort of standard the
camera pans to the
to
the health officials
and she's just
staring i mean
the point being that there's a serious i
mean the thing was ludicrous but there
was a very serious point in that which
is if a leader
shares
disinformation
then the anti-vaxxers and people stop
believing in the in the process i mean
presumably under a different leadership
it might be better for the us if there
was a point
that would be true would have been true
had there been different leadership the
first time we went through this and they
could people who could have been led and
so instead of 40 of the population
revolting against the right thing to do
would have been 20
um but now they've revolted and dug in
their heels they're harder they'll be
much harder persuade persuade i mean
there will be a assist if there were
right now if a more lethal pathogen
swept across the united states there
would be an instinctive and well
organized resistance to doing anything
to defend ourselves michael just bef
just before we end
i hope you don't mind me asking you
about this as as you were writing the
book on covid and what was going on your
own family experienced an unbearable
tragedy your daughter i hope you don't
mind me asking you about her your
daughter dixie um died in a car crash
right as the book was coming out
um
and
it's been the hardest year of my life
she was she was 19 she was with her
boyfriend ross who was a year older ross
schultz and they
drove in
broad daylight head-on into a truck and
um it makes one aware of a few things
very quickly
one how precious life is
and uh two how it can change in a
heartbeat
and three
th
the amazing
thing to me right away
was i'd never had i've never had that
this kind of grief i've never
experienced this kind of loss my parents
are still alive and flourishing
um
and
instantly
i was admitted
as a kind of
citizen to the kingdom of grief and made
aware
of how much of this there was around me
to which i had been oblivious close
friends
how and and especially now how much loss
people have endured
in the past couple of years
and there's a psychology to loss
and
but it's an it's an inarticulate
psychology people behave differently
when they've experienced the loss and it
expresses itself in strange ways
i'm just trying personally
to navigate it in my own way so i
minimize the damage it causes i loved
her so much i was so proud to be her dad
she was just the best human being and
she was going to change the world
i can't do anything about the fact she's
gone all i can do is make sure that
what happens
next
isn't worse or bad i can just try to
respond in positive ways to it
i think that
i cannot speak for other people in their
grief
but
in my case
um
the experience
which
experiences of loss is a loss of love
and leaning into love
in various ways in response to her death
has been enormously healing leaning into
other people's need for love
um
so it it's
um
the most the tempting mistake
that i think we've been avoiding
is denial just on the writing you've
written about finance you've heard about
policy written about so many things do
you think now you might write about
grief that that might help other people
grieving
um
yes
i'm not quite sure what form the writing
is gonna take
i know it won't take the form of a
how-to
because i do think
i think it's so peculiar the the
experience of grief
is
suey generous that yeah every grief is
grief is grief but it's not each
person's grief is different it depends
on the nature of the loss the nature of
the relationship you had with the person
who's lost who you are how your
chemicals work
so i would be very hard i'd be very wary
about telling people
how to go through this experience except
to say however you're going through it
is fine
walk in and embrace what's peculiar
about your own response
because this there's some truth in that
now how
i write about it
i've got some ideas about how i might
write about it but it's it's i'm not
going to ever be in a position of
preaching to people
or
how they should experience their own
loss that wouldn't be my
my style well thank you for talking to
me about it because i'm sure that many
people watching it find it very
comforting because i don't think any of
us talk about grief we don't do lots of
enough we don't do lost well and and a
lot of people live through it and and
find it hard
so thank you andrew i thoroughly enjoyed
our conversation thanks for coming on
thanks for having me